[Music]
here's your money briefing from Monday
June 12th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
for a lot of people The Daily Time
commitments of work and family life
leave little room for me time but why do
men win the me Time battle more than
women Wall Street Journal work and life
columnist Rachel feinsick joins me to
discuss the importance of me time in
your schedule and tips for adding it in
so Rachel why is it more of a challenge
for women to find me time than men what
I heard from folks was that there's a
little bit of a double standard there's
this societal expectation that men's
main job is to be a breadwinner so when
they get home from work everything else
is just kind of extra and when women get
home from work their actual job starts
which is taking care of the kids and the
house and again I mean this is a broad
generalization it's not like this for
every couple but these are kind of the
cultural messages that many of us have
absorbed and that kind of feed into
feelings of guilt among women for
example and leave people feeling really
stretched does this idea of men and
women having different levels of ease of
bringing in me time does it have to do
with what their career is not
necessarily because what we see from
this recent Pew data that I included in
the story that helped to kind of inspire
it is that even when making similar
amounts of income men still get about
three and a half hours more leisure time
per week and that's true when women are
Breadwinners as well men are getting
even more extra leisure time per week so
I don't think it necessarily has to do
with our careers we've certainly seen
more female Breadwinners in the United
States in recent years I think it kind
of goes deeper than that so what can
women learn from Men in terms of fitting
me time into their schedule Allah
talked about just
prioritizing this recognizing that it's
so important to get this kind of me time
this kind of leisure time so that they
can be better fathers better workers
also this I this idea I think that not
everything has to be perfect I talked to
this one dad who goes mountain biking
and he was like you know if I come home
a little bit late and I don't get a
chance to start fixing dinner until a
little bit on the late side No One's
Gonna Die you know and I think that's
good advice for everyone to to keep in
mind that it is worth prioritizing this
even if it makes some of the other stuff
feel a little bit less perfect so having
a bit of a flexible schedule at home
that can actually help you yeah and I
think also having a flexible approach to
Leisure again this guy that I talked to
who's a devout mountain biker he doesn't
have set days per week which he goes
which when we think about habit forming
as kind of a frequent piece of advice
and actually when I started swimming
with a girlfriend of mine this past year
I was like oh we need to pick a day like
a Monday that way we will commit to it
that's just not possible for a lot of
people that have really busy lives I
have found in this guy that I was
talking to also found that actually
being flexible kind of fitting your
leisure time in around other obligations
because you're not gonna not go to your
kid's dance recital or you probably
shouldn't you know Skip your kids dance
or settle you're not going to blow off
that big project at work and so I think
when we have unrealistic expectations
like you were saying Jr like a lack of
flexibility this idea I either do it on
Tuesday nights or I don't do it at all
that's the wrong approach I think we
want to kind of try to fit it in around
the rest of our stuff in our lives
because that stuff isn't going away how
much does this have to do with the way
people visualize what me time could be
yeah think sometimes we have
unreasonable expectations we think this
like perfect moment is going to come you
know where it's total quiet and it's
just gonna feel like this relaxation
descending upon us and what I heard from
folks especially one career coach told
me was it doesn't feel like that
especially right at the beginning you
know you might successfully carve out
that half hour and you sit down and that
to-do list is still running in your head
or you can hear your kids screaming but
you want to just try to sit with it and
know that it's a practice and it will
get better and it's worth doing even
when it doesn't feel like the moment is
perfect because chances are that perfect
moment is never coming so what about
self-accountability here what kinds of
commitments can people make just force
them down this path to bring in some me
time because it sounds like they may
have to dislodge some habits that are
hard to break yes I've heard a lot from
women especially feeling like they can
only do this when it's like productive
me time it was like this kind of this is
the first time I was like no that's not
what I'm writing about but then I
realized that is how a lot of people
especially women see it it's like oh
yeah leisure time is the time when I'm
networking or learning to code you know
that's my me time so all of that in mind
the way that you can build some
accountability around this is first of
all pair up with a friend then you have
built-in social time it kind of is a
two-for-one and I know with myself with
the swimming I mean I would just feel so
bad ever bailing on my friend that I go
swimming with that it's really kept me
accountable you can also pay money for a
class join a group that can help with
accountability as well you know getting
some me time getting some relaxing time
can probably go a long way and so
regardless of your gender how can not
taking time for yourself affect things
like your life and your in your overall
career well people get burned out first
of all they're exhausted they're not as
creative you know they're not as
productive they think it can also be
really harmful in relationships people
feel resentful and what I heard from
this one career coach was we think it's
anger but it's actually probably more
like jealousy like we're jealous if we
see a partner or other people getting
more more Leisure Time and so it's
really important to figure out a way to
take this to make this current pace of
Life sustainable that's Wall Street
Journal working life columnist Rachel
feinsick and that's your money briefing
I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall Street
Journal
[Music]
foreign